so welcome back everyone um so now we'll
have the last Talk of the day by P indic
visiting us from
MIT all right uh can you hear me
well all
right all right so uh the talk is about
fast approximate algorithm for a
transfer distance uh it's a paper uh
that will uh soon appear in a new rips
2023 uh it's a paper joined with a this
fine people okay uh this is uh who they
are uh you know just for the clarity
asand is the guy on the left uh the guy
on the right is Max he also contributed
but uh he's not officially coauthor of
this
paper all right so so I guess the first
time you see this title of this talk
right I mean the main question is what's
the Cher distance right I I kind of kept
it uh uh you know mysterious right I
mean there is no abstract right uh all
right so uh who knows what's a Cher
distance uh okay so I guess everybody
else again Eric did introduce in this
talk like a day or two ago unless I who
who who did it er er Eric oh Eric all
right okay uh Eric is Eric here yeah
okay to go all right not to raise my
hand I see I see all right all right
okay so some of you know uh most of you
don't right so uh I'm going to Define it
it's a it's a distance between two uh
sets of points right so I'm going to
refer to them as a point clouds right
because that's that's often how they
refer to in practice okay okay so uh you
have two sets of points right a the blue
one and B the red one and the Cher
distance is uh from A to B is simply the
sum over all uh points on the left of
their distances to their nearest
neighbor all right so basically it's the
sum of all the points of the length of
those
edges it's a it's a very natural notion
and uh you probably seen uh uh
definitions which are at least somewhat
similar to it right so for example uh a
very similar definition is a house door
distance right where the only difference
is that the sum is a replaced by Max
right so this the maximum uh maximum
distance you know here it's the the
average or the sum of the distances and
of course another very uh similar notion
is the F distance and I'm going to talk
about it you know the connection in the
in the next
slide all right now generally speaking
this s distance function can be
arbitrary for the purpose of this talk
we just think about as being L2 or L1
right but uh you know the whole notion
and some of the algorith actually more
General than
that all right so I'm going to refer to
it as a
distance uh not a metric right because
it's not a metric right it's it's very
easy to see and actually it's not aetric
you know like there are not just one but
there are two strikes against it okay so
it's not symmetric okay which is very
easy to see right because uh the
distance from Blue to red right the some
of this but uh oh but if you want to
compute the distance from red to blue
you have to include uh you know this
distance right and you know it can be
much larger than uh the other way
around so this is typically not a
problem if this is a problem uh it's not
address by just symmetrizing it right
the same thing as for House of
distance uh so it's one reason it's not
a metric another is that there is no TR
equality it's also easy to see uh
typically people just ignore this fact
uh it's inconvenient sometimes but you
know what can you do all
right so uh this is the uh the
definition any questions to this
definition because that's probably like
the most important slide in the talk I
mean it's it's very simp yes
youm I actually don't know yeah it's a
it's a good question I don't think so
but I I don't know the question for the
oh I'm sorry yes so the the question is
do you get triangular quality after you
symmetrize
it uh yeah if somebody figures out
during my talk I I'll I'll appreciate
[Laughter]
it uh any other
questions all
right all right so uh I already
mentioned that a Cher distance is uh
quite Clos related to earth mover uh to
the point that uh it's actually
sometimes called relaxed fover distance
right and it's easy to see why uh
basically this is another way of
thinking about Cher distance right it's
the minimum overall mappings from Blue
to Red of the distance of the of the sum
of distances along the edges right and U
if you restrict this uh minimum so that
the functions are required to be one to
one okay you get exactly the earth mover
distance or to be more precise it's a
uh version over the uniform measure
right you just assume that it's Earth
distance over sets of points as opposed
to multi sets or or or measures so this
implies that this is a lower Bound for
this okay
uh the Gap can be large right it's it's
generally
unbounded but this relationship uh makes
it actually very useful in a bunch of
applications and uh the reason is that
uh you know it's pretty clear from this
definition that this is much easier to
compute than this right you know this
you know there is a trivial algorith in
DN Square time you know this is a
non-trivial optimization problem so
because of that people often use
transfer distance as a proxy for EMD
right which is easier to compute uh to
the point that some papers in particular
this two refer to it as a relax EMD okay
again modulo the fact that you know here
have defined it for sets and and this is
measures but other than that it's it's
the same uh however you know uh Cher
distance has application on right right
connections to MD is important but there
are many other uh there are many other
applications and the applications kind
of varied over time right so
uh maybe except for the last uh uh like
maybe three decades ago or two decades
ago uh popular applications were to uh
measure similarity uh or dissimilarity
between uh low dimensional shapes right
so you know for example here have an
example right you have a one incomplete
shape you have another complete shape
right you want to see how different uh
they are I mean you have to align them
first right but modul of that you know
it gives you some measure of a
dissimilarity for low dimensional points
Point sets uh now over the last uh maybe
10 years another popular set of
applications uh went beyond uh shapes
and in particular involve the point
clouds in a higher Dimensions okay so
this is a one example how many people
have seen this example
before all right yeah it's a it's a
fairly fairly known example it comes
from the paper from the previous slide
uh it's referred to as a word mover
distance okay so the idea here is that
you can take for example documents okay
like this one and you can map each uh
word into a point in some relatively
high dimension space right you know for
example using you know word to V
embedding or or or something like that
right you take a word and you transform
it into uh actually I don't know what
dimension is 64 or or or something like
that Justin looks like he knows
but yeah so basically you can model a
document as a a set of points as a cloud
in a high dimensional space right you
know two documents and then you know to
compute the similarity the documents you
can just compute some distance between
those Point clouds okay in the paper uh
the authors use ultimately they use a
earth mover distance right so hence the
name we mover
distance but uh it's not so easy to
compute so they use transfer distance as
a proxy right basically they have a
pipeline they want to find a set of uh
nearest Point clouds right so they use
transfer distance as a first
approximation and then you know they
filter and they compute the actual wor
mover distance only for a a subset of
the points so this is this leads to
another set of nice applications but at
this time in high dimensional spaces
right
just and last but not least uh you know
of the last 10 years people used the
Deep learning a lot right if you if you
didn't notice uh and uh chaer chaer
distance found many applications there
basically in deep learning you you know
like whenever you want to predict or
regress a shape right you you have to
have some notion of a uh distance
between uh the uh what you predict and
the ground truth okay and people often
use a uh Cher distance to do that right
precisely because it's a it's it's it's
a much more efficient than Earth M
business all right so it's been used
around and uh it's been implemented in a
bunch of libraries you know both for
deep learning and uh for comp ing Point
clouds right so it's a it's a useful
measure to uh you know for various
applications all right so uh how quickly
can we compute it uh so well let's
assume for Simplicity uh the uh sets A
and B are both of size n in the
dimensional space and let's say that the
distance is a distance or L1 okay so you
know this is the trivial algorithm
despite the fact it's trivial actually
many if not most uh implementations I've
seen actually implement this right so uh
uh you know there is nothing to say here
um you know however already U 20 years
ago people notice that okay I mean this
is a pretty dumb algorithm right because
really what we want is a sum of all the
distance to nearest neighbor so we can
as well you know use some uh intelligent
data structure right for uh Computing
those distance to your neighbor uh in
this paper uh uh these authors use KD
trees uh you know of course now we have
many more algorith for computing nearest
neighbors and uh if you use uh
state-ofthe-art
algorithms you roughly get this type of
run times okay I'm putting here run
times for the one plus approximate uh
nearest neighbor right to one plus
approximate approximation to Cher
distance
right so in low Dimensions uh you can uh
compute both build the data structure
and make nend queries in roughly this
time right so it's a very efficient
terms of n it's like depend logarithmic
but you have this Cur of dimensionality
right and uh uh uh this might not be the
state of the art I think state of the
art might have minus something here but
uh it's you know approximately the the
state of that right you have to pay this
exponential dependence on the
dimension in high Dimensions things are
bit different the run time is no longer
logarithmic right it's n to some uh you
know complicated looking uh
exponent uh the basic idea is that this
exponent is smaller than one as long as
Epsilon is greater than zero you get
some sublinear time
algorithm uh it's not logarithmic but uh
at least you are not paying exponential
dependence on the dimension okay and to
the best of my knowledge this is
actually the state of the art uh like
this is the best algorith I have seen in
the literature all
right all right so uh this seems like
something we should be able to improve
and uh that's exactly what we what we
did right this is the uh state of the
this is the prior work uh the main or
one of the two results in our paper is a
one plus approximation in basically this
time okay so uh you know we improve both
over this and uh and
this uh on top of uh that uh the
algorith the algorith actually is a is
fairly simple okay I I'll explain it uh
uh you know in the talk and uh it's not
only simple it's also you know clean
right I mean it's it's easy to Implement
it's naturally paralyzable and and and
so on right uh so and last but not least
it empirically fast right so we are we
are hoping that after proper
implementation this thing you know could
actually be used in a bunch of in a
bunch of
places now crucially I know that this
algorith here approximates the value but
it doesn't approximate the
correspondences right there's no it does
return the assignment right and uh and
this is there's actually a a reason for
it uh uh basically you can show that uh
a run time or we show in the paper that
the run time of this form is not
possible to achieve assuming a so-called
heating set conjecture how many people
have heard about hitting set
conjecture all right so a few fans of uh
fine grain complexity are heard about it
how many people heard about orthogonal
vectors conjecture okay many more all
right so so this is a something which is
uh it's a much stronger or or stronger
assumption than orthogonal Vector
conjecture and uh you know orthogonal
Vector conjectures relate to soal a
strong exponential time hypothesis which
in turn is a much much stronger version
of P not equal to NP okay so like after
you know you mention all this you know
after we do all the strengthening right
I mean you know it's you know one can
argue whether you know you should
believe it or not
you know whether you believe or not at
the very least that points out that that
there's some barrier right that if you
uh get if you improve over this you know
you you also uh disprove you know some
conjecture at least some people believe
you okay
yes I was curious like the natural
language or other applications are there
some good settings where you don't need
the
mapping right right so uh so for example
example uh in this
setting okay so let's go back to the
applications
um yeah so here you don't need the
mapping uh because uh uh you use transer
distance here to compute the nearest
neighbor respect to EMD so what you
really care is the distance right and
you approximate this distance the EMD
using transfer distance right you find
uh a few close points respect to
transfer and then you run EMD on it
right so here you you you just need the
value uh uh here uh it really depends I
mean uh often you don't need the
correspondence as sometimes you do for
deep learning it really depends right if
you just use it as a loss function then
you don't need the correspondence but uh
uh but
sometimes you need more than just the
the the the value of the
function yeah I mean it's I I cannot
really say like what's the ratio but uh
there are many many applications that
I'm aware of that use only the
value yeah although often they you
know let's not get
[Applause]
yeah all right so uh so these are the
the two results sorry yes
can you say what does it mean you
cannot So when you say you cannot get a
bound of this type you mean ND polyon
over Epsilon or all right uh so uh right
so the formally uh we can reduce a
heating set problem to uh this problem
with a Epsilon being one over
polan so so basically there is a an
indication that already for a you know
sub constant but not very uh big
Epsilon
uh the running time has to be you know
quadratic right so like two to the one
over Epsilon might be okay still two to
the one of Epsilon there is no evidence
there is no evidence for that and what
about do I mention sorry about uh well
so the uh hitting set is hard already
when Dimension or conjecture to Beal
already for Dimension being Pol
logarithmic
yes sorry maybe just a baselines
question um and maybe I misunderstood
why can't you use the nearest neighbor
data structures to estimate each of the
distances like to a constant or log and
then important sample and compute them
exactly so that that's essentially what
we are doing right as I said the
algorith is not complicated right okay
yeah yeah yeah it's just that in order
to get this running time we have to do
something a little bit more great thank
you any other
[Music]
questions all
right so uh what is the algorithm uh the
algorithm essentially follows uh Aron
suggestion right uh
uh with a one uh twist that I'm going to
get into in a moment right so basically
we approximate uh you know we start by
Computing the approximation of the uh
distance to the nearest neighbor okay so
for each a we get this
da uh the approximation is kind of funny
in the sense that uh we don't want to
underestimate right so uh uh you have
always this this holds always uh but uh
uh in terms of overestimation we only
care about it being on average right uh
and of course you know what you
suggested also gives you that right
uh
okay uh so uh so we execute uh this
thing here and uh after okay I gave this
talk earlier to more applied people okay
so there'll be some concrete numbers you
can just ignore them okay so you uh
uh well I I I I'm not sure if
theoreticians are that happy with actual
numbers right so you you know you can
you can you can just
uh you know they're not there all right
so uh uh right so after you perform this
estimation uh what you do is uh you
compute the uh basically you know
normalize it so that this is a
probability uh and uh you know each
probability is proportional to the
estimated distance and uh all you do is
sample this many uh points from this uh
probability distribution and uh for uh
each point that you sample you compute
the actual distance okay so basically
this is this is important sampl
okay and then uh when you output your
estimator okay the you know the standard
thing important sampling is that uh you
basically have one you know here in the
estimator you have one over this
probability right so that the
expectations in the expectation you know
this and this
cancels and uh uh the expectation is the
is the correct one all right so that's
uh that's basically the whole
algorith
okay all right so uh why is this thing
correct uh well the expectation uh uh
you this estimator is correct you know
again because of standard argument for
the uh uh whatam I call it uh important
sampling okay basically this and this
are inverse which means that this things
cancel
out uh variance can be bounded as well
and basically the the bound comes from
comes from this okay uh you know this
Factor here directly come comes into the
uh Bound for the
uh well square root of the variance
right which in turn affects the the
running time right so this Logan is
basically this Logan
here okay and these are these are like
standard facts about important
sing so uh how much time does this take
right so this you know clearly takes uh
this time right because we are sampling
this many points and for each we compute
the exact right so it's a
DN uh you could imagine faster algorithm
for for reasons it's actually plugging
in some faster near nebor algorith
doesn't seem to be uh giving anything
that we
know and uh what's the runtime of this
well you know I didn't describe how this
works but uh turns out that the run time
is a DN Lan right so you basically have
DN Lan here here you have DN Lan over
Epsilon square and and uh uh and that's
how you get the whole Alor yes could you
use the nearest approximate with Epsilon
like oh no you can you can yeah so uh
this is basically your suggestion right
yeah but before we get to to that any
questions about this like if you ever
seen important sampling this this this
goes through very all right so uh the uh
the the main question is how do you get
get this a crude approximation to the
sum or to the distance to the nearest
neighbors and uh uh well as you as you
suggested right uh one way to do it is
to basically build the nearest neighbor
data structure with some crude
approximation and uh you know you just
query this and and that's it right so
this certainly gives you uh this
property right and also this property
right because all distances are
approximate up to again it's more than
we need but you know certainly you get
this yeah the only problem is that uh
it's uh tricky uh to do it in exactly ND
times Lan time okay uh so the the uh
like the I'm happy to be uh corrected
but uh uh you know like all algorithms
that I'm aware of you know they have U
run times which look like d n over one C
or or or things like that right you know
this is for L1 but there are this are
pesy uh logarithmic factors right
sometimes they're not logarithmic
sometimes they n to smaller of one and
uh since we want to have a very fast
algorithm
uh you know basically they just a
compound okay so uh what we do instead
is uh go back to First principles the
final algorith is actually quite simple
still but to B on my know we need to do
something else right in order to uh
something more in order to get this
estimators right so we go to First
principles we get the weeker guarantee
right instead of each distance being
approximated up to Lan we just get that
the expected value of
Thea Logan was in this right and then of
course by Mark of inequality you get a a
good
approximation all right so how does the
algorithm actually look like okay it's a
quite similar algorithm to uh if you
ever seen uh how many people have seen
hierarchically well separated
trees style yeah all right yeah so it's
a uh it's a HST but with a one
twist uh so what is HST uh or what is
HST uh uh restricted to this particular
setting uh it's basically
quatri uh where uh the point set for a
point set which is shifted by a random
amount okay you take your point set you
shift it by a random amount and then you
build a quatri right so what's the quri
right this is the uh top uh
node right uh then you subdivide into
four parts right so these are four other
nodes and you know just keep subdividing
this you know until you get the leaves
okay
uh so that's a standard
quadri uh yeah and then the distances uh
you know it's well known that uh in some
expected sense the distances in the
between two points are well approximated
by the distances in the squaty right
when the uh three edges have some
exponentially varying uh weights
okay uh you know alternatively you can
just think about it in in this way right
that for each point here okay you uh to
approximate the distance to uh near near
s right you find the lowest level such
that uh the cell of this note contains a
point right and then you set the
distance to be equal to this right so
basically for this point okay you have
to go to the top level to find a red
point right so this could be this but
also could be this but for this point
here right you you actually find the red
point in this cell so you can get this
as an approximation
okay so this will be uh pretty much like
a standard HST now the the only twist
that we make is that uh unlike in
standard HST we actually use different
random shifts at every level okay so
it's not that we shift once and then
just a subdivide we use different random
shifts at every level so you know
instead of
this looking like this okay you can get
something like this okay it's no longer
nested so in fact it's not even a tree
at this point right I mean it's a if you
want to connect it to some weird graph
but you know you can see that this
definition still goes through right
basically to find the distance you just
find the you know lowest level when you
actually have some point of the other
color and then you you you connect
it and uh and that's uh pretty much it
oh by the way I should mention in
practice we just use standard quatri
right we don't randomize you know it
didn't make any difference in
experiments right so we just keep it
simple but for the analysis is a it's a
crucial and uh the reason why it is uh
important uh uh is basically the
following okay so I'm not going to give
the full proof but I'm just going to
give the
intuition right so first we need some
notation right so consider some level
okay which we are going to parameterize
by a scale okay a scale is just a
parameter you can think about it as a
scale being proportional to the diameter
right of this the grid up to some you
know factor of D or
so uh and uh uh you know for uh let's
age uh R ofx right with the uh grid cell
uh containing X right so each HR
corresponds to a level right of a scale
R and for any point x HR of X is the GD
cell containing X okay and then you know
it's a known it's well known it's very
easy to see that uh the probability of
uh you know for any two points X and Y
the probability that those points are
Collide or not Collide you know it's a
close related to the distance between
them uh in particular
if the scale is much larger than the
distance right so you can think that you
know have two points very close and the
grid cell is pretty large right then
this dependence of uh this two cells not
being equal is a linear in roughly at
least bounded uh from the above you know
as a linear function of the distance
okay now you know if this a distance you
know grows at some point it goes uh
beyond the scale uh then you have the
opposite right probability that uh these
two points will actually fall into the
same cell is a exponentially small
inance so these are fairly standard
properties of something like this right
and extends to like fairly general
setting basically any I mean not quite
right but essentially any local
sensitive hash function you can just
plug in
here all right so uh uh so let's say
that uh I consider one a and I consider
there uh that b to be the true nearest
neighbor of a in
B then we know what you can see is that
U um you know the typical situation
right is that uh when the scale is
around the true distance then you know
this A and B Collide and moreover uh no
other point in B whose distan is are
much larger than scale will collide with
a right because uh you know this is
dependent exponential right so once you
exceed this by Logan right the
probability of collision is very small
right so this is the the typical thing
meaning that this is what happens with a
constant
probability uh and if this happens you
know everything is good and you know
like you don't need this independence of
different levels but uh you know like
the an also has to take care of the tail
probabilities right so what happens if
uh uh two points start to collide only
at the higher level right so they don't
Collide uh at this at their scale okay
so then you have to go to higher level
and having Independence there you know
just means that probability is multiply
right so uh yeah so in the end you know
like you can write a bunch of unnested
sums okay and you uh you basically uh
using the the dependence property you
know you get that uh the average
Distortion is a logarithmic
all right uh does make sense has there
any
questions go ahead just making sure you
get we need the login in order to get
high probability and say that for every
point you get a good approximation uh uh
yes
yeah I mean it's a bit more complicated
right because at the end we just care
about the expectation right but uh uh in
order to get this expectation uh we have
we have to be able to handle the the
tail probabilities right so the the
analysis is a point by point right so so
there's no Union bound at the end right
but uh you you you you have to be able
to deal with a situation where this a
first Collision doesn't happen at the
proper level right and and then you know
like if the things are independent that
youur that okay you go to another level
you get another shot right and you know
like very quickly the probability uh of
uh going very high uh to get a collision
it just goes down very
quickly so maybe
just so as a flip side to the question
we cannot guarantee that without like
with a large enough constant for every
Point you'll get a Logan approximation
no right and because that'll be that'll
be against your lower bounds eventually
uh if you had that you would have a
mapping that would be uh well I mean it
would be
a it wouldn't be against the lower BS
because we would get only Lan
approximation right uh and Lan
approximation we can actually get in a
you know if we add extra polog we
actually can do it right okay so uh okay
uh yeah so we don't have a lower bound
but that the analysis doesn't go through
okay thank
you
all right so this is all I had to say
about the algorith or the analysis are
there any
questions
yes so instead of building a quad tree
right one thing you it might be possible
to do is to like make random choices
along excuse me along each of the axes
but then would you lose the property
that points nearby stay in the same cell
across different level
is that what you need to do this type of
thing yeah basically at least for the
analysis you need to know that uh you
know HR and let's say H2 R uh they are
independent all right yeah so at the end
it's a very simple algorith analysis is
not complicated at all right just a
bunch of equations I mean honestly this
algor could have been discovered uh 20
years ago uh for some reason hasn't been
uh so uh you know like we we we are we
are happy we managed to to find
[Applause]
it all right uh so that uh concludes the
uh Theory all right so I have to finish
I guess in eight minutes right give or
take all right so uh uh all right so
let's me now uh talk more about the uh
the
applications uh
uh okay so this is a uh you know like a
prototypical uh result that we got uh we
run this uh we implemented this uh uh
you know by we I mean my co-authors
right we well we right we implemented
this uh this algorithm uh and run it for
two types of data sets right I mean you
know you have a you know 3D or a low
dimensional and a high
dimensional uh
uh data set for low dimensional setting
we use the shape net data set which is
uh you know a collection of a point
clouds that uh look uh very similar to
the examples with a plane right we have
seen earlier right so this is one set of
applications this is for uh U you know
using it to compute distance between the
uh
documents and this are the type of
results uh that we uh that we got okay
we compare uh our algorith to two
baselines one is a kd3 I think it's a
standard kd3
used inlab if I remember correctly it's
a fairly standard package and we also
compare our algorithm right which is
here to just a simple uniform sampling
right and uh uh you know like not
surprisingly right with the our
algorithms are syn faster on kd3 right
you of course you know it's a bit Apple
to oranges right because this algor gets
a exact solution right well here we get
approximate but the you know the error
is very small right it's like a few per.
so uh uh so that's pretty good uh
uniform sampling uh perhaps not
surprisingly uh is slightly worse okay
in the sense that uh so what it means is
uh yeah basically we have to uh we fix
the error or the empirical error and we
uh
sample enough samples so that we get the
same error in both cases okay so uh you
know important sampling has to pay for
computing this approximations right so
there is some some fixed cost but then
uh you need fewer samples right so you
you basically get a uh algorithms faster
you know here the difference is not very
big you know here it's like factor of
two or something right and uh you know
compared to uh both uh in in both cases
compared to kd3 right it's a the the
Improvement is a
significant question
yes did you choose the number of samples
according to the to the analysis or you
chose it sort of optimist you chose it
just right to get the right error yes so
basically for both uniform uh and the
important sampling we uh uh we chose it
just right all right so in a practical
setting what would you recommend what
are you telling the
practitioners how what do you what are
you telling the practitioners to do sure
when they want to get an error that's
small uh sure yeah so
uh uh ultimately so you know right now
the code is U somewhere there it's a
code for the paper uh but uh ultimately
you know like when we you know actually
release a code that we can you know like
advertise uh we want to uh use this uh B
want to choose the number of samples as
the analysis right so that we we have a
guarantee that uh with you know at least
this probability you are going to get at
most this much error yeah it's a a
little tricky right because if you just
plug in Expressions I mean you know
there are Big O constants uh all over
the place right so this is we we haven't
done it yet but uh that's the that's
that's the goal now you know I suspect
that in practice like especially for
people who use it as a loss
function um no nobody really will care
uh you know we just basically said you
know uh let T be 100 right and uh uh and
that's it right but you know like it's
certainly much more it will be much
better right if we can get a similar uh
uh you know good results while actually
preserving the guarantee yeah so that's
a that's an important
issue oh sure
so I guess from the previous slide it
seemed like the relative gap between the
sampling algorithms in KD tree is sort
of similar in 3D and in high dimensions
and maybe I would have expected the Gap
to be a lot bigger in high high
Dimensions if there's a
reason yeah it's a good uh good
question uh
I mean right so you're talking about the
Gap not the actual right because the
sizes of the yeah yeah yeah um yeah my
guess is that
uh what happens is that both kd3 and
important sampling but basically I I you
know my best guess is that the
approximations of the probabilities are
actually uh uh better there than here
right so the runtime uh is you know
longer right for kd3 but also the the
approximations here are worse
[Applause]
sure yeah now we need to double check uh
to to to give us answer with confidence
right yeah also you know this data sets
I mean they're high dimensional but
there's lot of structure there right
[Applause]
so oh sure follow up on my earlier
question so it seems
not that it's great algorithm I I like
it I I I'm concerned in the previous
slide that that when you actually if you
were to do it not in an instance
specific way but based on the on the
worst case analysis right that you're
gonna you're that it's not going to uh
improve on even the uh on the running
time for the exact algorithm right see
why I well just just I'm just wondering
I'm speculating given that you have to
you know this the dependence on Epsilon
and and uh the Big O uh constants that
you know how much room do you have how
much wiggle room do you have to get an
improvement significant enough to give
up ex uh the exact yeah I see I see uh
right so again it it could depend on the
uh application so you know like the
answer is you know I don't know because
we we haven't done it yet right we we
actually you know we're planning to but
you know at some point we have to submit
the paper right so sure it depends on
what I I understand it depends on what
accuracy they're really looking for and
if they don't if if they don't really
care about accuracy or if the accuracy
can be right if the error guaranteed
error can be 50% or something like that
right but but then it also raises this
another issue which maybe you can
speculate on which is is there is there
some method like uh some other stage of
sampling that will give you a feel for
that will will G give you better
constants on an instance per instance
basis right right so
um yeah so that's effectively what we
were trying to do right we we try to uh
estimate the variance as we go right
uh yeah but I mean like ultimately start
to get complicated right and so we just
decided to all right so let's let let's
set the parameters and uh right I mean
the you know the only thing that I can
say in the defense of this uh approach
is that uh you know both this and this
basically we're using the same right for
you know both the Baseline uh in
sampling and this we we are doing the
same thing right um yeah and you know
there is a fair amount of we have a
buffer right because this error you know
2% uh I mean you probably don't need 2%
right so we can get a much uh faster
algorithms uh you know if we have a
higher error right uh but yeah I mean I
we we don't have this experiments yet
and uh that's something that we would
like to do
yeah question do you have some sense do
you have some sense of how what fraction
of this is spent in the first log and
approximation and how much is the is the
exact competition uh I have I have this
uh data but unfortunately I don't
remember yeah sorry about I
don't actually in a way in
directly uh indirectly and yeah I have
to finish pretty soon right uh yeah so
indirectly the this uh slide uh which is
basically the last slide um answers
that um so here we did another
experiment right basically uh we
compared uh the quality of the
estimation by you know our algorith and
newform
sampling um as a function of the number
of samples right and uh um you know as
you can see you know the uniform
sampling the gap between uniform
sampling and the uh important sampling
is a smaller in low Dimensions than in
high Dimensions right so presumably once
you invert this result you probably can
get some sense of the of the run times
uh right
uh yeah I we have those plots I just I
just don't remember
them and uh last uh thing that we did
you know we cooked up a synthetic data
set right so so where the gap between
important sampling uniform is the
biggest right it's it's where the cloud
Point Cloud they compare have outliers
right so uniform sampling is not going
to find them but important sampling does
and you know so not surprisingly you can
make this Gap uh large right now this
are synthetic data so uh uh you know
this Gap here is much bigger but you
know you can see that the Gap is also
significant
for all right and uh this is pretty much
it right so uh this is what we we have
seen uh this generalizes to weighted
Point sets other distances basically
anything that supports lsh and uh we are
hoping that uh you know if we work uh in
the implementation in particular would
like to do uh you know uh what you
suggested uh this potentially could be
useful algorithm but yeah I mean we are
not not there yet thank
[Applause]
you any other questions for
p so you guys have this um lower bound
to say that you can't uh construct an
approximate mapping right correct uh so
I guess I have two like questions
vaguely in the neighborhood sure uh the
first is using a simar like fine grain
complexity analysis or something like
that is there notion of if you don't
care about outputting the mapping is
like a better dependence on Epsilon or
is a better runtime otherwise
possible uh I see can can you do better
than DN over Epsilon Square L right yeah
we we actually uh we actually don't know
what the what the answer to right you
know basically the problem is that
the yeah you could you could imagine you
know like set Epsilon to be one over
poan right and then make some sort of
reduction right uh we we don't we don't
know okay yeah and then second question
is uh suppose you care about like a deep
you know the Deep learnings SGD sort of
situation and you're okay with like a
noisy gradient in the sense that maybe
your turn like a partial mapping from
some points some other points is there
any hope there that maybe yeah yeah like
a low variance partial mapping right so
uh all the experiments uh that I showed
here they basically apply to this uh
first two settings which is uh okay it's
going to take a while before I get to
this slide with applications right so
both you know experiments were here and
here right so when you have a uh actual
uh you know data right uh for uh loss
functions you are perfectly right that
basically you know you can plug this
into the our algorith into the formula
for the loss function uh we have no idea
how this is going to work uh right so
this is something that uh we haven't uh
tried uh
yet
uh yeah basically everybody was busy
with uh but this is uh uh one of two
things that we want to look next you
know just take one of this uh uh you
know there's a bunch of papers which uh
do regression for for shapes right so uh
you know basically just replace whatever
uh sub rutine is being used with
everything and see what happens right we
have absolutely no guarantees that it's
going to work uh right because uh
uh we have no guarantees on the you know
that this mapping preserves the gradient
uh in any way right uh but you know like
deep learning is a remarkably uh robust
you know and uh you know essentially
what we need is uh to get some uh
approximation of the direction right
because even if we get things wrong uh
you know we we we can still improve it
later right so yes so we are planning to
do it empirically we have absolutely no
Theory
thank
questions so that's everything is
geometric here yes uh ukan space uh the
way I described yes Ian you could
imagine uh this this being some Metric
function so so could you ex if you
wanted to extend it to metric spaces oh
because some of these applications seem
to be more like metric than
geometric uh which ones I mean distance
between backs of
words uh oh oh I see well I mean it's a
distance between uh bags of words but
the
uh you know Cher distance is a metric
right but the underlying uh distance is
a UK
metric right so uh I I I don't know I
don't know I so so so this D in your
case in the so the the analyst was using
quarries so you're using ukan
space uh right so I describe it in terms
of quarries now really what you need
uh all the way uh forward what you
really need is
uh
uh what you really need is a this a HR X
right so you know as long as you have a
some way of hashing your points with
this property uh everything goes through
right now this means that you can use it
for you know like things related to
Jacker distance and whatnot but I mean
really it's like variance of L1 right so
to you know to to yeah so like in short
uh if the underlying distance is uh
something more complicated
done uh muan Oran or or something
something this we don't know the answer
okay that could be for
gentics I think that is a simple lower
bound but okay I don't want to
yeah any last
questions then let's thank
Peter
now now the schedule says a discussion